today i want to take a few minutes to
tell you about a really innovative
platform doing some very cool things in
the world of decentralized finance defy
and the project is called la cucina
we've partnered with la cucina to create
this video essentially what la cucina is
doing is incentivizing defy users to
discover great defy projects which
otherwise might get overlooked by
rewarding users with extra benefits when
providing liquidity without the user
needing to stake the foundation of la
cucina
is and really what they're setting out
to do
is remove the inequities that we often
see in d5 because la cucina believes
everyone should have the same ability to
reap the rewards of their crypto but la
cucina applies this egalitarian
philosophy to d5 projects as well
there's too many barriers for people
trying to set up
a farm on a major decks
your project already has to be huge for
you to see success so a lot of smaller
but well deserving projects get ignored
and lost in the mix
la cucina's solution to this problem
is to create a community oriented defy
platform that stimulates engagement
between projects and users and la cucina
drives this by offering rewards for user
engagement which in turn grows a
project's community we wouldn't call la
cucina
a defy exchange per se
in contrast la cucina works with
exchanges to complement them it's an
engaged community where d5 users who
want to find great projects actually can
and users can judge projects by their
merit instead of by their size so la
cucina puts these projects in a much
better position to compete with bigger
projects but how does it work let's talk
about one of the central innovations
that la cucina is bringing to the table
called external farming which la cucina
uses to promote emerging defy projects
on the platform la cucina monitors and
supports a long list of d5 projects and
they're always adding more to the list
if you're someone providing liquidity to
liquidity pools for one of these
projects on a major decks outside of la
cucina
blacina's external farming lets you get
even more benefits on top of the swap
fees you've already been earning you can
farm earnings without having to stake
anything or move your stakings another
really important concept in la cucina
are what they call ovens and now we're
getting to why it's called la cucina
which of course means the kitchen an
oven is similar to a crypto farm which a
lot of us are familiar with an oven lets
you get extra perks without having to
stake and with tons of flexibility and
every oven in la cucina every oven in
the kitchen
represents a liquidity pool and each one
has what they call cooking plans each
cooking plan is a reward policy being
used to promote different parts of
liquidity provisioning like the timing
or the duration or the amount so cooking
plans are what determine the allocation
of the rewards among liquidity providers
every cooking plan is just a
mathematical function which i won't get
into but it's interesting to read about
the math behind it on la cucina's medium
page on
in an article that explains how it all
works nfts are also a major component of
la cucina you can collect buy and sell
nfts on the platform you can actually
cook the nfts in the kitchen too a lot
of people complain that nfts don't do
anything nfts on la cucina are not just
things to look at although you know the
art may well be great but each type of
nft on la cucina has a utility on the
platform and there's a few different
types of nfts they serve different
purposes secret ingredients dishes
italians talions are the tradable
customizable sort of like someone's
avatar inside la cucina and when you
cook the secret ingredients together
you'll get a new nft
the reward boosting dish the dishes have
a multiplier from 1.1 x to 10x
and they can be activated in any oven to
increase your share of rewards in that
oven all of the nfts kind of fit into
the lore of la cucina in a fun way where
everything is part of the story and this
is where everything's gamified so you're
doing something useful but there's cool
art and stories involved as well the la
cucina platform went live on february
22nd after a beta test that went really
well so this is an exciting time for the
project and the community i've been
checking out the platform the interface
is really easy to use and navigate easy
to get started you pick up some lac
tokens on buy swap or mdex the
platform's native token connect your
wallet check out what la cucina has
going on they're providing some new and
useful benefits to crypto projects
trying to get off the ground which is
great but they're also giving new types
of bonuses to users which is really what
drives all of it la cucina's medium page
is really informative lays everything
out in a way that's easy to understand
i'd recommend that and i want to thank
la cucina for partnering with us on this
video the link to their website is below
this is my thought process about the
project it is not a suggestion that
anyone do anything in particular with
their finances or buy anything or sell
anything anytime you want to do anything
that involves your money you should do
your due diligence
consult whatever professionals you think
you should and make the decision that is
best for you